[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special
edition of i'd like to know ca murray
here in the presence of our speaker and
founder pastor stephen bohr pastor good
to have you here as always it's always
good to work with you
we like working together we like
studying the word of god and we are
taking questions now uh live uh which we
don't always get a chance to do but this
is fun also so what we're going to do is
have a word of prayer and then there are
a couple of questions that we have that
are directed directly to you pastor so
we'll have you lead out on those and
i'll chime in when uh when and if the
spirit moves me to do so with your
permission and then we'll move on and
then as questions come in we will add
them to our our list but let's pray
father god we do thank you we praise you
for your goodness and your grace we
thank you and praise you for your love
we thank you and praise you for the
power of your word we thank you and
praise you that our you are our alpha
and omega and that all things are
centered in christ jesus so father
be the center of this program everything
that is said and done the answers that
are given from the word of god may they
be just the answers that
the individuals need to draw them closer
to jesus and to strengthen their faith
in him and we thank you father in jesus
name amen and amen amen
pastor you've got a question there that
i think we're going to take a look at
that was directed to you and they they
were highlighting specific
points of specific statements that you
made perhaps you can walk us through
that
uh well actually we have two questions
here related to bible prophecy
and
i guess i'll take this one first
i've watched most of your anchor
and many other evangelistic series
i thank you for your clear description
of last day events and historicist
eschatological interpretation
one thing puzzles me in all these videos
why do you focus so much on the sea
beast
of revelation 13
instead of warning folks about satan
impersonating christ
as ellen white describes in great
controversy 588
through
page 592.
this to me seems more likely to
interpret the final verses of daniel 11
and revelation 17 and 18
this event the counterfeit second coming
precedes sunday observance legislation
so please
advise
the interesting thing is that satan
before
the millennium
works by stealth
i read those pages from great
controversy 588-592
and you know they could be interpreted
as satan personally
performing the miracles and the
supernatural signs uh the counterfeit
second coming that is described in
matthew 24 if he's in the desert don't
go out if he's in the rooms don't go out
but the problem is that if you read the
statement carefully ellen white is
describing the papacy that boasts of
miracles as performing those miracles as
an agent of satan yes because satan is
not doing it directly yes he's doing it
through the sea beast and also through
the beast that rises from the earth
because it says in revelation 13 that
the beast from the earth performs great
miracles even making fire come down from
heaven in the sight of men yeah satan's
not doing that directly he's actually
doing it through
his his two agents yes the sea beast and
the lame beast yeah yeah i and i think
your point is so well taken the land
beast of course appears in chapter 11
and goes on but he's been what satan is
doing he's been doing by stealth and i
think your void is right on for a long
time
using agencies and so when you spend
time in the first 10 chapters of
revelation 13 you are seeing the the
history you're seeing the progress
you're seeing how he's been using this
beast for years and years so you're not
shocked when you see activity at the end
because what he has been doing he's been
doing a long time through covert means
and i think you are dead on with the
idea that he's been doing it by stealth
now his hand will become more and more
visible as we approach the end but you
need to see the history so you can
understand how he has worked through
these two beasts particularly the the
sea beast for centuries uh he's been
using that and uh uh i think that answer
is is right on pastor well you know an
interesting detail that we find in
revelation chapter 16
and i'm just going to read here
oh i have my spanish bible believe it or
not i'll have you read it
revelation chapter 16 verse 13. alrighty
16 13 and i saw three unclean spirits
like frogs coming out of the mouth of
the
dragon out of the mouth of the beast and
out of the mouth of the false prophet
this is from the new king james
okay so you have the dragon the beast
and the false prophet
um what does the beast represent well
the papacy what does the false prophet
represent it's the same as the beast
that rises from the earth yes and it's
also mentioning the dragon but the
dragon is actually satan working through
the kings of the earth yes let's go to
revelation 19. there's an interesting
variation in revelation chapter 19
that describes the final battle
revelation
19 and verses 19
and 20.
and i saw the beast
the kings of the earth excuse me the
kings of the earth and their armies
gathered together to make war against
him who sat on the horse and against his
army and verse 20 then the beast was
captured and with him the false prophet
who worked signs in his presence by
which he deceived those who received the
mark of the beast and those who
worshipped his image
these two were cast alive into the lake
of burning fire with brimstone
do you want 21 also
no just 20. okay now here's the
interesting nuance
revelation 16 verse 13 mentions three
powers the dragon the beast and the
false prophet
revelation 19 19 and 20
mentions the beast
it mentions the false prophet the
prophet yes but instead of the dragon it
mentions the kings of the earth yes the
kings of the earth is a substitute for
the dragon because
like you know the dragon stood next to
the woman to devour the child as soon as
a child was born well satan did not
personally stand next to next to the
woman to slay christ as soon as he was
born he is the king he used king herod
correct and so here you have satan
before the millennium
working by stealth yes in other words he
works through the kings of the earth
and the false prophet yes and the beast
but when you compare revelation 16 13
with revelation 19 19 and 20 you see
that the dragon is equal to
uh the kings of the earth yes uh now
another important thing is you know
there's this theory that's going around
i'm not going to mention any names about
who is really
you know spreading this idea
that the counterfeit second coming of
christ
is going to take place
during the period of the sunday law
before the close of probation
but really when you examine this
carefully the chronology
satan's counterfeit second coming
is actually something that happens
after the close of probation
and you see that because of the order of
events that we find in matthew chapter
24.
so if we can go there just for a moment
to matthew 24
uh which by the way is in chronological
order
um i did a whole series on matthew 24
which has 24 presentations
and
the word then
in the chapter is used nine times yes
and it indicates something that happens
after something else sequence so it says
then this then this then this than this
and it's interesting that in matthew 24
and verse 21
you have the great time of trouble it
says for then there will be great
tribulation such as has not been since
the beginning of the world until this
time nor shall ever be very similar to
daniel chapter 12 verse 1 a time trouble
such has never been seen since there was
a nation
and so and then in verse 23 it says then
that is when the tribulation is going on
the great tribulation
then
if anyone says to you look here is the
christ or there do not believe it for
false christs and false prophets will
arise and show great signs and wonders
so as to deceive if possible even the
elect that's the counterfeit second
coming according to ellen white in great
controversy
so clearly
satan's attempt to counterfeit the
second coming of christ takes place
during the great tribulation after the
close of probation
not before the close of probation
in fact ellen white has uh her statement
in great controversy about the
counterfeit second coming or satan
trying to counterfeit the second coming
is very interesting it's in the chapter
on the time of trouble
which would seem to indicate that it's
going to take place during the time of
trouble after the close of probation
and
ellen white even pinpoints the moment in
which satan is going to attempt to
counterfeit the second coming
she has another statement where she says
that god's people are going to be crying
out day and night for deliverance from
their enemies from the death decree
which is after the close of probation
they're going to try to execute the
death decree yes and she says that god's
people are crying out to god day and
night for god to deliver them
and she says at that moment
satan is going to
offer his counterfeit of the second
coming and he's going to tell those who
are crying out
i have come to answer your prayers yes
i've come to deliver you
so very clearly when you look at
the several statements by ellen white
this is taking place after the close of
probation of course some people ask the
question they say well what good would
it be for satan to counterfeit the
second coming after the close of
probation if all cases are already
decided he's not going to be able to
deceive anybody by doing that
but you know that
basically
uh is answered by saying that satan even
though he knows that he's not going to
be able to deceive the elect he's still
going to make the attempt yes and the
example that i give is this
do you suppose that satan knows that
after the millennium
uh when the wicked resurrect and he
rallies them to conquer the city do you
suppose the devil knows that he's not
going to be able to overcome the city
that fire is going to come from heaven
to consume it do you suppose he knows he
surely does he is not enough a student
of scripture to know that uh and if he
doesn't he's not very smart because
revelation chapter 20 tells us right
so here's the question
the wicked resurrect of the millennium
the righteous are in the city
satan rallies all of the wicked
organizes them militarily to attack the
holy city why does he do that if he
knows that he's not going to be able to
because the devil is the devil precisely
he harbors the he harbors the idea that
even though matthew 24 says he's not
going to be able to deceive the elect
because when it says if possible the
elect later on in verse 31 it says that
jesus is going to gather the election
yeah so if he gathers the elect they
must not have been deceived
exactly and and so
satan does this because he's the devil
he doesn't give up he says maybe this
once i can counteract what god has said
in his word and there's nothing good in
him to make him want to change i mean if
if anything good comes out of our life
it is christ dealing with within within
us he has none of that right so there's
nothing in him to make him go any other
way than the way he's going his own
inertia will have him go to do that
because there's nothing good in him to
make him change right so so i believe
that um
clearly
when you see that the counterfeit second
coming satan's attempt at a counterfeit
second coming yes uh is in the chapter
on the time of trouble matthew chapter
24 it's in chronological order during
the great tribulation after the close of
probation that it's pretty safe to say
that the counterfeit second coming of
satan to try and deceive people to think
that christ has come takes place after
the close of probation and not before
the close of probation and the answer to
the question as asked is why would you
spend so much time on the first beast is
because you get to see an image of the
history of the the surreptitious
movements of satan down through the ages
so you can excuse me be prepared for
what's going to happen in the future
because you have a sort of prologue of
history on what he's done in the past
sure
and satan once again he works by stealth
yes he's going to work through the beast
from the sea
and through the beast from the earth yes
that is the agent of the beast from the
sea but he doesn't exactly appear right
when is he going to appear so that
people can see him it's during the great
tribulation when he attempts to
counterfeit the second coming of christ
that's not going to be the that's not
going to be uh you know the the systems
that he uses it's going to be him
herself yes
and his agents well done well said uh
and i'm glad you took the time with that
because it it does clear up for us
some questions and it was a good
question it's an insightful question
and uh your answer is very very good yep
all righty okay the second question has
to do with
my study notes
on
it's actually called from the close of
probation until the second coming it's
the last anchor class that i did
well not the last the next to last
anchor class that i did
and this is the question
um
let me not read the whole thing
it is what you state at the 19th minute
of that presentation while you refer to
daniel 11 45 speaking about the king of
the north he shall plant the tents of
his palace between the seas and the
glorious holy mountain
and then he states what i stated you
said that the seas
is to be understood as the mediterranean
sea
and that the tents are military tents
this implies a literal interpretation
instead of a symbolic one
as most prophetic passages daniel 11 is
highly symbolic
and therefore i have always understood
daniel 11 45 as follows
the seas represent the multitudes or
people as defined in revelation 17 verse
15 also is drawn from the symbolism of
daniel 7 2 and psalm 65 verse 5.
the tents represent a counterfeit of
this true sanctuary tabernacle in heaven
which offers the only way of salvation
the glorious holy mountain is then of
course the heavenly mount zion where
god's people will finally be gathered
and then the whole meaning i thought is
this the papacy plants its influence
between the people and the final message
hoping to prevent any more people
from hearing the gospel and being saved
so it's quite a complicated question
but
you know i've interpreted the seas
uh as representing uh you know the
mediterranean sea
and the glorious holy mountain as
representing mount zion uh and the the
king of the north as the papacy
[Music]
and really there's no contradiction
because the mediterranean sea becomes a
symbol of the multitudes
who are intent on destroying god's
people mount zion is not literal mount
zion it's uh where god's people are
gathered at the end of time 144 000 are
gathered on mount zion
and the king of the north represents the
papacy
so so you have the symbolism of the
mediterranean sea the symbolism of the
glorious holy mountain yes but neither
of those are literal they're symbolic
so it's just a matter of kind of
connecting the dots and following
through uh from the symbolic presence to
the to the the the actual thing uh and
and that works right it does so anyway
that is a short answer to that
particular uh question
now this person actually watched the dvd
presentation or maybe watched it on
youtube i would recommend
that uh that this person who asked the
question which is a very good one uh
would go uh
to look look at the study notes because
the study notes have a lot more
information than what i presented in in
the class
so i would suggest that this person get
the study notes which have much more
information yeah and evidently they're a
student of the word they've they've
watched it enough to know exactly the
moment of time
the frame where you said it so uh do a
little more research and you can get the
whole picture right so well done okay so
those are the two questions that uh that
we had
um there's probably other questions that
you have there all right here is a
question that's interesting this person
wants to know about
the will um
do i ask the holy spirit or the father
to give me willpower
i guess they're having trouble dealing
with something so they want to to know
how do i go about uh praying do i ask
the father holy spirit to pray in the
name of jesus so uh a couple of things
come to mind one i just happened to have
some uh a little study i did on the will
uh by ellen white that i just sort of uh
have that with me
but
a couple things i want to say about
asking asking um
the bible says in james 1 17 that every
good gift every perfect gift comes down
from the father so that says to me
pastor my pastor my friend that whatever
i want i ask of the father
but christ said to ask it in my name
so we ask of of the father in jesus name
that's the order that's the mechanism so
um
uh
john first john chapter 5 verses 14 and
15. now this is the confidence that we
ask anything according to his will he
hears us so it's not just saying just
ask anything you want i want a new car i
want a new vet i need a new wife owning
a house you know you want to ask in the
will of jesus if if the bible says this
and you ask for that as contrary to this
you shouldn't expect that because you
ask in the
will of christ but you ask in the name
of jesus and you ask the father so um
and ask for ev everything that's that's
the mechanism for everything
now he he wants to know about the will
and
you know i've got three or four pages
here um she talks about giving your will
to christ she says uh putting your will
i'll read this as one thing from the
fifth around the testimonies page 513
looking at my time pure religion has to
do with the will the will is the
governing power in the nature of man
bringing all other faculties under its
way the will is not the taste or the
incarnation but it is the deciding power
which works in the children of men unto
obedience to god or unto disobedience
now you have certain people like um
uh joseph bates who had an incredibly
strong will
he read that
we shouldn't drink he put the glass down
never picked it up again
he read that children of god shouldn't
smoke he put the pipe down never picked
it up again he did that through force of
will
most people aren't that strong you know
uh and and even if not you want to do
things in jesus name so you get uh you
get christ involved um
uh
but but uh
what i think she's telling us is that
what we've got to will to do
is to serve jesus
and then allow his
life to be worked out in me if i say
i'm not going to think about this lovely
woman
every moment that i'm not thinking about
her i am in effect thinking about her
because i'm thinking about not thinking
about her you follow it's a little
convoluted but that's a deal
so what i've got to do is i call it
putting jesus at the point of attack
i've got to not think about not thinking
about her i've got to put jesus in place
of her so it's a replacement kind of
thing i think about jesus and what
christ wants for me and that gives me
the strength to resist uh because there
are some days when you wake up your will
is strong your other days when you wake
up your will is not so strong those are
the times when you really know you need
jesus if you're going to be successful
and many times when your will isn't
strong when you got up it's because you
didn't get a good night's sleep
yes tossing and turning thinking about
what you will or will not do
you know
there are some things about at the fall
and sin and they're saying of course sin
has over these many many centuries
weakened our will weaken our will power
you know so really we need we need we
need christ or we're almost defeated
before we start satan is many things but
he is not stupid and he is not a quitter
he is incessant and he is he is uh
insistent so we need to be in christ
every moment every second of every day
if we're going to be successful i think
it was mark twain who says quitting
quitting smoking is very easy i've done
it a thousand times
very very very true he was a master of
saying indeed indeed but that's the
point that there's very little willpower
you know
but there are some people who can say
i'm not going to smoke anymore
and they pray to the lord i've had
people tell me stories where they pray
to the lord they have this terrible
smoking habit two packs a day and they
pray to the lord and they've told me
that they've had no desire whatsoever to
smoke after that i mean it's not been a
real
big struggle to overcome smoking and
there are other individuals you know we
have the five-day stop smoking plan
which was done in the past
later it became a seven day plan and i
don't know if they're still done but you
know those are methods that help the
willpower of people to overcome smoking
or any other habit
but the holy spirit is the one who makes
us willing to be willing
i like that it makes us willing to be
willing because i've i've had people who
who have by willpower stop doing things
and have others who had the same problem
but they agonized with it year in year
out year and i came to a church and
found out one of my deacons was still
smoking and he i mean he cried and he
shed tears but it was just bigger than
than he was and we we we got him off but
it was not it was not easy uh be
because of the the
you know the predictions that man has so
it can happen but sometimes it's it's
it's work to get it done very difficult
yeah well uh the main thing is the will
becomes stronger as we use it amen is
that right amen you know it's kind of
like faith yeah faith becomes stronger
when we have obstacles
and we are successful we successfully go
through those uh and come out
victoriously on the other side yes there
was a question here and i don't have
right in front of me uh where someone
asks about this does the lord send us
trials and challenges uh uh what would
be your answer to that question i think
the lord allows
uh challenges to come to us obstacles to
come to us well said and the purpose is
not to break us but to make us amen the
purpose is to strengthen us because if
there is no opposition
there's no growth
because it takes a decision of the will
to say i am not going to get discouraged
by this yes and pray to the lord and say
lord help this experience to strengthen
my relationship with you not to lead me
to give up yeah it is a
a factor of human life that muscles that
are not used atrophy yeah they're
they're going to uh not be there when
you need it it's not going to be there
so when when a person is exercising when
you start from point zero your trainer
will tell you the first day you you you
go at it the next day you are going to
be sore oh you're gonna be you're gonna
you're gonna ache in places you didn't
even know you had why because you're
using muscles you had not used before
the muscle breaks down and then it
begins to build itself back up but
you've got to keep on exercising keep on
exercising and sooner or later those
muscles begin to come back alive and
they get stronger it is very much the
same way as you would have said in in
the spiritual realm if you don't get
challenged if we just our faith does not
grow
we need the challenges for our faith and
it's so very true god is not trying to
wash us out he's trying to shape us up
and the only way you can do that is is
through putting trials in our if
everything was easy uh then well we we
just kind of sit back and take the path
of least resistance but you've got to
fight your way into the kingdom you know
and
and work with the lord i always like to
say that faith is an action word amen
lots of people believe that faith is
something that happens in their brain
they kind of uh believe it's a synonym
of believing
but you know you look at hebrews chapter
11. everybody's doing something
everybody's doing you know they're not
only believing god they're showing that
they believe god by doing what god has
asked them to do yes you know noah
builds the ark moses leaves egypt yes
and you have abraham taking his son to
sacrifice his son abel offered a
sacrifice yes all of them are doing
something and they're growing in their
spiritual experience by doing yes yes of
course james uh begs the point that that
faith is demonstrated by works by taking
the chance to do what god says even
though sometimes it doesn't make sense
to you it's counterintuitive does not
add up that's when when it doesn't make
sense that's when your faith really
shows and if it made sense to you it
wouldn't be faith
well faith without works is dead and a
dead faith can't save you so
so we need to put our faith into action
we need to put our actions where our
words are in other words praise the lord
praise the lord you know and i just need
to pay you this compliment in a time
that remains when you began this
ministry you didn't know where it's
going to end up you didn't know what was
going to happen you just stepped out in
faith
put in the work put in the time put in
the sacrifice
going wherever the lord was leading and
today we find a ministry that god is
using around the world to do great
things for him that's that's what faith
does your faith is has proven and god
says prove me test me try me you will
find that i am faithful
and i love that thought about god well
you know we've made obstacles along the
way but every time that we look back we
say thank you lord for the obstacle
because
we can see his hand working
well time's about up yes indeed well
hopefully this has been a blessing to
you again we like to have your questions
we'd like to give answers from the word
of god and we promise you always to do
that
our time is fast lived into eternity
allow me to wish you both grace and
peace through our lord and savior jesus
christ we'll see again soon on i'd like
to know
[Music]
you